an ending that will have fans of the
books split
a king infected with dark magic and abs
and me quietly sobbing when Alina says
goodbye to Mal this season of Shadow and
bone is an epic tale that follows Alina
starkov as she aims to destroy the fold
once and for all and in this video we'll
be taking a look at its ending and what
it could mean for season 3. don't worry
if you haven't read the books this video
won't have any book spoilers so power up
your amplifiers and make sure to like
And subscribe because here we go the
final episode is called No funerals
which is a bit ironic considering the
amount of deaths that occur including
that of the darkling himself Alexander
morozova also known as kirigan the
entire season has built up to this
moment where Elena starkov the sun
Summoner must use her power Amplified by
the Stag the sea Whip and the firebird
to destroy the fold for good but while
Alina Ventures Into the Heart of the
full to save the kingdom of ravka her
betrothed Nikolai lansov also known as
the major of the 22nd regiment soldier
of the king's Army Grand Duke of udova
Second Son to Royal Majesty King Peter
III and ruler of the Double Eagle Throne
that's a mouthful must fend off
kirigan's forces but ever since the end
of season 1 kirigan's been able to
seemingly control these shadow creatures
known as nishvoya these creatures killed
nikolai's brother in episode 4 making
Nikolai next in line to the throne this
is important considering Nikolai and
Alina agree to a marriage of convenience
in order to unite the Grisha those who
possess magical abilities and the rest
of ravka but Nikolai is attacked and
almost killed by one of these Nish Voya
and take a look at how he clutches at
his chest after the attack later in the
episode we'll see that he's been tainted
by this Shadow which does not bode well
for ravka considering he's set to become
their next king but we'll get to that
insane coronation scene in a bit at the
heart of the fold a final confrontation
takes place between Alina and kirigan
kirigan has come to stop Alina from
obtaining the final amplifier the
firebird which we learned has been her
childhood best friend Malian oritsev all
along in fact Mal is of the more zova
bloodline making him a distant cousin of
kirigan hundreds of years ago Ilya
morozova also known as the bone Smith
created three amplifiers the Stag the
sea Whip and the firebird amplifiers are
creatures or beings that can
significantly amplify a grisha's power
when bhagra elia's daughter accidentally
killed her sister using the cut a rare
Grisha ability to telekinetically cut an
object in half Ilya brought her back to
life this type of magic was forbidden
and the villagers ended up executing
Elia however his daughter survived and
her bloodline flourished all the way to
Mao this is why Mal and Alina have
always been drawn to each other the two
are destined to be together but this
also raises an interesting question are
Mal and Alina in love with each other
because of Destiny some external force
or is there love true we'll get to that
in a moment but for now Alina and
kirigan Duke it out each using the cut
but notice how both of their abilities
are different kyergens is that of Shadow
and Alina that of blue light for Alina
this is significantly different than The
Shadow cut she uses at the end of the
episode which hints at one of the
episode's biggest twists the fight
between Alina and kiergan leaves both
Mal and kiergan mortally wounded in
order for Alina to integrate Mal as an
amplifier and destroy the fold for good
she must be the one to kill him it
hearkens back to what kirigan said to
her in episode 1. are you willing to
sacrifice that which is the most
precious to you now armed with the power
of all three amplifiers Alina is able to
destroy the fold and all the volcra
within it leaving only a desolate scar
on the landscape where the fold once
stood but kirigan is still alive
clinging to the belief that he and Alina
are meant to be the two balance each
other out light and darkness and only by
uniting together can they stop the
persecution of the Grisha by creating a
new world as they see fit Alina rejects
this and Kerrigan says she'll one day
regret that decision he's lived for
hundreds of years has seen those he love
grow old and die he's seen the hatred
and pain Humanity has caused and this
will happen to Alina too she will harden
and eventually make the same decisions
he did and when she tells him there's no
Redemption for him and nishfoya escapes
from his body and attacks her for most
of the Season we are led to believe that
kiergan controlled these monsters but
it's actually the other way around and
not only that he's been trying to keep
them at Bay from coming after Alina
watch as he tries to stop the Shadow
from hurting her and later says without
me
no they will come for you we know that
the destruction of the foal did not kill
the Nish Voya so consider them a threat
going into season three luckily inej has
her magical blade known as nishanier
this was a blade forged by sanctin AR
the patron saint of blacksmiths who is
said to have fought off a horde of
clockwork soldiers saving shuhan in the
process we meet this woman in episode 6
who lends the blade to the crows to
fight off the darkling this also gives
Alina a purpose to visit shuhan next
season not only to forge a relationship
between Brava and them but also to
return the blade Alina is half shuhan by
birth which will undoubtedly help in the
matter with the full destroyed ravka is
no longer split in two which poses a
significant threat to the fiordans to
the north the United rafka is not good
for them the fear didn't see the Grisha
as Abominations and believe they should
be eradicated from the world they are
led by a powerful and ruthless group of
witch Hunters called the druschkel
Matthias being one of them although over
the course of season 1 learns to to
question his Prejudice as he falls in
love with the Grisha by the name of Nina
zenik poor Matthias this season has had
a rough go of it having spent the entire
time at Hellgate a brutal prison and to
make matters worse he was put there by
Nina in season one Nina had to lie and
say Matthias was a slaver to save him
from being killed by a group of Grisha
she had to do this to save his life this
was to save your life they would have
killed you that's why when Nina first
discovers him at Hellgate and they lock
eyes he doesn't acknowledge her he still
doesn't trust her sonina's journey this
season is all about springing him from
jail which has her joining it with Kaz
Brecker and the crows who offer her a
chance to save him ultimately it's
Nina's work helping Alina and Nikolai
that gives Matthias a full ravkin pardon
but when she goes to free Mathias she
finds him pitted against two wolves
which is problematic since wolves are
seen as sacred to the fieridans but even
more concerning is the fact that no one
seems to care that Nina has this pardon
and we leave season 2 with Matthias
still in prison and Nina escorted away
Nina also knows that it was Alina who
was the one to resurrect Mao not her as
a heart render Nina possesses the
ability to start and stop hearts in
which he tries to save Mal you can just
see in her face that she's unsuccessful
so how then does mal resurrect the
answer mirzost mirzost is corrupted or
dark magic with unpredictable
consequences in fact bagra makes Elena
swear that she'll never use it sweat to
me you'll never use it that's why I mean
it go but we can see that she does just
take a look at her hand as merzos flows
through her veins as she brings Mal back
to life Nina also tells Kaz that it
wasn't her who brought him back to life
you combine all these with the fact
Alina uses a Shadow cut to destroy the
feared and woman at the end of the
episode it's clear that mirzost has
started to corrupt her but his
background warned her we aren't exactly
sure in what ways this corruption will
manifest is it possible that kirgan's
warning is true that she will eventually
become just like him could this be
singling that Alina is on the path to
becoming the next darkling what's also
interesting here is that everyone sees
her using this dark magic how are they
gonna reconcile their future Queen
potentially being corrupted by this now
Mal's Resurrection also has this side
effect of him losing his Grisha tracking
abilities he can no longer feel Alina's
pull which makes him question whether
what he had with her was real Destiny or
some sort of magic so he decides to
leave on his own Journey taking up
nikolai's Alter Ego Sturm Honda as a
privateer and should this journey lead
him back to her he'll know what they
have is real choice
not destiny
Choice here again's corpse is burned
Alina doesn't want any crazed Heretics
taking his body as some sort of Relic
nor since he's a morozova his bones
being used as amplifiers Nikolai makes a
speech about the destruction of the fold
and the unification of ravka but Nikolai
is holding a dark secret just how will
his infection manifest and alter the
ways he rules the country then there's
the question of this guy the apparat who
we saw in season one think of him as a
priest for the ravkin king and his
conversation with Nikolai is quite
confrontational with him even suggesting
that there are those who could undermine
his Ascension there is a rumor that he's
the bastard son of the queen and a
feared and Ambassador a rumor he
confidentially tells Alina is likely
true but publicly denies meanwhile Alina
points jenya and Zoya to oversee things
at the palace poor genius had a rough
time this season getting mixed up with
kirigan and her face disfigured not only
that but she lost her romantic partner
David and will later find drawings of
the wedding ring fitted with a ruby her
favorite that he was going to propose
with jenya is put in charge of turning
the palace into a refuge for anyone who
needs it while Zoya will oversee Grisha
training and eliminate the kefta Garment
worn by the Grisha to separate the
Grisha into various orders in Nash is
also said on her own Journey when Kaz
gives her the news that he's been
secretly looking into the whereabouts of
her family his only lead are the slave
auctioneers Who Sold her so when we see
inezia board the same ship malazon and
then they find a slavership you can bet
this will somehow tie into her origin
story but then there's also the question
of Kaz and inez's budding relationship
he wants her to stay but isn't willing
to touch her with his gloves off as a
boy Kaz lost his brother in nearly his
own life to fire pox and had to use his
brother's corpse as a float to get
ashore ever since then he can't bear to
touch another person's skin hence
swearing those gloves inej wants him
with his quote armor off and until he
can learn to move on from his traumatic
past and take those gloves off he's
forever doomed not to be with an edge
but with an edge separated from him he
may have some competition is it just me
or does Tulia here seem to have his eye
on her so that leaves Kaz and the crows
back in ketterdam where Kaz has
reacquired his Pub and is on the search
for a woman named Cash in the book she
is said to have skills similar to an
edge so it looks like Kaz needs a
replacement but I'd place a bet that Kaz
will soon realize he doesn't know what
he's missing and that this separation
from a nej will only make his
relationship in the future with her
stronger the king's coronation has been
purposely set on the night of rinkela a
notable feared in Festival the king
calls this an opening Salvo against the
fjardin putting his coronation on the
most holy of fjordan days this is also a
smart strategic move on nikolai's part
as you can see who has chosen to attend
his coronation in who is not which might
give him some outlook on who's loyal to
him Nikolai also takes a brief moment to
talk with Alina and let her know his
feelings for her are true but he does
not want to be kissed by her if it's
only a means to forget about Mao their
ongoing relationship ship in season 3
will undoubtedly be tested and now that
he's infected with this Shadow it should
only seek to further complicate things
it also calls into question if this
Niche Voya has a hold of him and will it
be able to control him is this all an
elaborate ploy for it to get closer to
Alina Kaz also mentions the appearance
of a new and dangerous drug called
gerdap Haram in the books this was
synthesized using the highly rare jerda
plant only found in the shadowful but
with the shadow fold being gone just how
much of this could potentially be made
is unknown although never explicitly
stated in the book The chemist who
created this could be vladim kirgan's
Alchemist but this character was picked
up by the feridans in awaits trial this
is bad news for rafka because the drug
has the ability to amplify a gracious
power a thousand times and if they
weaponize it it could turn a war between
ravka and ferdin in ferdin's favor and
considering this female assassin speaks
fearden at the end of the episode after
ingesting the drug and attempting to
kill the king it's safe to say the
fjordans have already weaponized it so
next season we have a lot to look
forward to a war between fierda and
ravka Alina visiting shuhan and
potentially finding more about her
origin Kaz and the crows looking into
this new drug in Edge finding the slaver
that took her and her brother Zoya and
jenya rebuilding ravka nikolai's ailment
and Nina and Matthias reuniting but I
want to hear from you what your favorite
part of the season was and what you're
looking forward to most in season 3.
leave a comment below thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember Daddy loves you very much
thank you